hello everyone
this is the middle of may 2022 and over
the next month or so various institutes
and universities across the country are
going to have their examinations and
interviews for phd so i thought this
would be a good time to address some of
the very important questions which often
come to the students who are about to go
for phd
questions like whether to give
precedence to the institute or to the
research topic or to the
professor now if i were to discuss all
of these issues and there are so many of
them it would be a rather long video so
i have decided to
address these issues one by one in this
video i'm going to focus on the issue of
whether one should go with a new
professor versus whether one should go
for a senior established professor let
us first discuss the case of a new
professor when you are going to
work with a new professor
there are obviously some
advantages and disadvantages
the disadvantage one may think is that
the new professor is rather
inexperienced
and that may be so but there are also
certain
very important advantages for instance
the most important advantage is that
this new professor because he'll have a
little more time
at his hand he'll be able to devote
himself directly working with you he may
also be working on a rather fresh topic
please note that when you go to work
with such a new professor on a fresh
topic it is almost guaranteed that on
that topic he has himself worked very
recently
in his own phd or in his own postdoc
with his own hands so you'll have
hands-on experience literally on that
work
compared to that if you perhaps go to a
more senior professor or more
established professor who is perhaps
also beginning to
work on a new or fresh topic
it may not necessarily be true that the
professor has actually worked with his
own hands uh it may be true that he has
some fresh ideas in that topic but it is
not
necessary that he has worked with his
own hands
on that topic so there will be
definitely a difference in the quality
of the supervision that you will get
okay so in this particular case very
very special case it is perhaps with the
new professor that you are going to get
a
more stronger and more hands-on
supervision where the supervisor will
know the nuts and bolts of the topic
now you may think that okay this
professor is inexperienced maybe he has
not handled students earlier
but
please note that many institutes have
this policy that if a professor if a new
faculty member has not guided any phd
student earlier
then usually they go for some kind of a
joint supervision so where
a more senior member faculty member will
be working so maybe there will be two
supervisors for the student so the
it's great for the student actually in
that case so just because you're it
seems likely that you're going to work
with a with a relatively new professor
but if there is a possibility of of
working
like jointly with another professor it's
the best of both worlds you get the
freshness and the enthusiasm and the
hands-on approach of the new professor
as well as the experience of the old
professor
of the older professor another important
thing is that
when you're going to work with a new
professor
please understand that at the very very
beginning of his career he has a lot of
things to prove
okay this is true
that he he wants to prove himself to the
department of the institute
to the to the research community in
which he is working
and
uh and this means in the words of nassim
nicholas talib that he has actual skin
in the game very much okay skin in the
game he has it very much so your success
as a student
ties in directly with his success so he
will be very much highly invested in
ensuring that your phd work is
successful which is not to say that a
more senior member will not be invested
in your work but he will probably have
logically so less skin in the game
compared to a newer professor because he
has already established himself he has
already proved himself a more senior
member okay so these are some of the
facts now let us consider the case of
the more senior professor now
conventional wisdom of course uh
tells us that it is better to go with
with a senior
professor a more established professor
that is certainly true because there are
of course certain obvious advantages
he's
literally established his senior he has
a certain standing and reputation in the
research community that he's working in
he has already guided students he knows
the pitfalls that phd students fall into
and he is well aware uh how to uh
possibly avoid them
although even senior professors like it
ultimately boils down to the student
right so even if he knows what pitfalls
to fight the student may not be avoiding
it but that's a different story
altogether so overall he has a more he
has a better grip on the things and
please note that the relationship with a
phd supervisor it doesn't it does just
doesn't end with the end of the phd with
the defense of the student okay it is uh
almost like a lifelong relationship now
that means that if the professor is
already established then in the
immediate future
uh after your phd is completed when you
are going for some kind of academic jobs
or maybe postdocs then a recommendation
letter from such a senior professor can
actually be very very helpful like it
can
really add to the strength which is of
course not to say that a recommendation
letter from relatively junior professor
is not strong but
i mean i i hope you understand that if
people already know him that if he's
recommending something then that carries
more weight okay
however however there are certain
disadvantages also and paradoxically the
disadvantages that i am going to discuss
has
like directly to do with the same causes
which makes uh working with a senior
professor advantageous
so consider for example a senior
professor who is very well established
in fact so very well established that
he's like a big shot in the research
community that he's working in so what
happens is that he will probably get
invited to a lot of talks
invited talks plenary talks this and
that he'll probably have to travel a lot
he may be involved in a number of
different kinds of projects various
kinds of responsibilities and in general
what will happen is that his attention
is going to get divided okay whether he
wants to or not his attention is going
to get divided this is fact although it
is great for his own carrier but a
student like a new student who is just
starting to work
with him he will
like
like just imagine for yourself you would
want to have some kind of direct contact
at least in the initial days on a
regular basis if that is not happening
because
because the professor is so very
much already
booked and
engaged with other things
then
it may be a little bit disadvantageous
for you so there's another side to it
also
so not just necessarily a big shot
perhaps there is a senior professor
who
is not traveling that much but even
within the institute or within the
department he is
burdened a lot with administrative
responsibilities this is a fact okay
this is a reality which always happens
the more senior a professor gets
invariably some kind of administrative
responsibilities will come his way
unless he is actively trying to avoid
those things
but that is somewhat exceptional cases
usually it happens so when
this more senior professor is so much
burdened with administrative
responsibilities and please note that
these are very very important
responsibilities like without
somebody doing those things
like carrying out these responsibilities
by devoting their time to it the
institute and the department is not
going to run
okay so these are absolutely important
but
from a very selfish point of view like
you as a student who is just starting to
work with him if the professor is every
day busy with these administrative
responsibilities
it may so happen that
there is like
there's some kind of a disconnect okay
the professor becomes disconnected with
what the student is actually trying to
do and especially in the initial days
this is
this can be really really
disadvantageous so what really happens
in those cases okay so
for these kinds of professors when the
student when a new student joins what
happens is that usually
since the professor is not getting time
to sit with the student on a regular
basis
what happens is that this student is
effectively mentored by a more senior
phd student or what is more common is
perhaps a post doc will will guide the
student effectively okay of course this
the the professor may meet with the
student maybe once a month or so
now this is not necessarily a bad thing
okay because
if you are especially involved in some
kind of experimental work
then
it is good to have have some kind of a
senior phd student or postdoc who is
helping you out
to to actually get to grips with the uh
the with the nuts and bolts of what you
have to do okay let the literally the
nuts and bolts of what you have to do
with the experiment so it's not
necessarily a bad thing of course this
is not to say that like working with
these senior people in the research
group is any substitute for actually
working with the professor you still
need to sit down with the professor okay
but please also note that there are very
much there are professors who despite
all the responsibilities despite all
their traveling
commitments and various other
commitments they still
take i mean make out time from their
extremely busy schedule to actually sit
down with their students almost on a
regular basis on a weekly
basis on a bi-weekly basis and
help the student okay there are
professors like that
but this is very very difficult like the
more senior and the more
responsibilities they
they have so my suggestion is that
if there is a possibility for you to
maybe
join such a
group
under a very senior professor
um maybe
write an email or so
to
to one of the members now in the in the
group the already existing group some of
the phd students who are working with
them try to find out what is the mode of
operation there okay how the students
operate how the professor is managing
the students
it is very likely that you may not get
any answer but if you never write an
email you will never get to know so
there's no harm in actually asking
and there's nothing wrong with that
now talking about experiments as i was
just
speaking a few seconds ago
when you are working with a
new professor
if this is a hardcore experimental area
then it can be a bit of a disadvantage
seriously okay because if the new
professor is yet to establish his lab he
has yet to buy the instruments get the
lab running
then
yes you when you join as a new phd
student in his group there is nothing
there in the lab so where are you going
to work on that can feel like a bit of a
disadvantage and it is it is literally a
disadvantage
but okay
there could be a positive spin to it
also
so
suppose you are such a first phd student
working with an uh professor on an
experimental topic and there is maybe
nothing in the lab okay extreme
situation so
what will happen is that
together with the professor
this new professor you are going to
build things from scratch like a very
hands-on kind of almost like an
entrepreneurial kind of thing that you
are going to do
and
this kind of
thing once you do it it will give you so
much
uh such a such a invaluable training and
a precious experience that
it can set you up beautifully for the
rest of your life okay
just considered a new phd student going
to work in a very established graphic in
a very established lab where everything
is already set up he just has to go
there and do his experiments based on
his ideas and another student who is
going on a lab where he's actually
helping to set up the lab and then doing
his experiments there will be a
tremendous difference in the uh
in the experience okay and this actually
this can actually show up in the
recommendation letter that this new
professor four years down the line or
five years down the line writes for this
phd student he will always have a
special
place in his heart for these
first one or two pg students who have
helped to set up the lab and when he
writes in the recommendation letter that
this has actually happened this can
actually go a long way in uh projecting
your own career
during your during uh through your post
doc and for your academic jobs okay
because you have already proved that you
can establish i mean you can help set up
a lab
okay
so there are pros and cons to uh to both
the cases of the new professors and the
senior professors so i have laid bare to
you
the facts uh as they are
so you decide what you want to do okay
and on this note i will i will end this
video with this with this piece of
advice that
you have to introspect a little bit
before joining
uh introspect in the sense that you have
to try to understand what is your own
personality what is your own working
style and please be very very honest
with the level of academic maturity that
you are at
okay this is very very important you
have to understand what level of
academic maturity that you are if you
are not very mature if you still like to
be mentored in a very hands-on approach
then
it is probably better that you go and
work with a new professor okay
and maybe if
you your working style is such or your
academic maturity is such that you can
handle being on your own
okay you do not need on a daily basis
supervision you probably prefer to be
left alone
then maybe going to a senior professor
is not such a bad idea at all plus
please also remember okay this is very
important uh that
when you go to work with a very senior
research professor you'll be sitting as
part of a large
research group okay so there every
research group has its own personality
there are very various issues associated
with it so you know whether you will be
able to play along well with others not
everyone can okay they are
they're more suited for smaller groups
as compared to larger groups so again
introspect
understand try to understand yourself
what will be best for you
okay
and of course try to be a little bit
flexible also just because you have
never worked with a large group but you
do realize that you have some kind of an
open mind
maybe you will be able to handle a large
research group so my advice is that
be brutally honest with yourself but be
also flexible when making these
decisions but above all please try to
make a
like an intellectual
from the brain decision instead of an
emotional kind of decision okay
so all the very best to all of you who
are going for the exams and interviews
over the next month